Jeff Coons art is not only a painting of
f sculpture for me art is everything
that excites and stimulates the
spectator well if this is Art then
everything can be art and if everything
can be art then what's the purpose of
what we can see in the
lra interpretations definitely but uh no
but I'm not I'm not at EAS with the idea
of
Kit um I think you know museums teach us
a thing is is the question of taste and
the change of taste M through time you
know there are things let's take vog vog
was completely ignored in his time and
reinvented somehow by the 20th century
uhhuh the Mir disappeared from the
Raiders for many long time reinvention
of a 19th century verir you know so
let's be modest about that there are
fluctuation of
interpretation
taste uh knowledge and we just have at
one point in our life we capture a
fraction and the Lou of today is not the
Lou of yesterday it has changed the way
it displays the things it display and
always been displayed like this and
there are many and probably my successor
will do different things and will maybe
make change so uh it's why this
definitive you know approach between
Beauty K you know it's one of the duty
of of of of history of art of museums is
to teach us to be curious also to
enlarge our vision all the time and the
Lou is not about one Beauty it's about a
thousand different kinds of beauties and
I think that's very very important you
know for me I mean I I think that beauty
might be a rather distracting word and
that I I I I you know how do I how do I
uh decide what I think is great and what
isn't great
and it is that I think it has engaging
content so um for me vanov Potato Eaters
no engaging content one of his
self-portraits totally engaging I
believe vov painted great self-portraits
that were better than anything we could
see in a mirror MH and it had content
and so I think that it's like people you
know it's not whether they're in the
right shape it's they engaging and do
you think they have
depth